l'un des gérants de l'enseigne Fitness
Boutique à l'île de la Réunion
l'enseigne finesse boutique à la Réunion
et spécialisée donc dans deux segments
stratégiques que sont la
commercialisation des produits
diététiques pour les sportifs confirmés
débutants et également sur la vente de
matériel de sport pour les associations
ou les particuliers actuellement la le
marché du sport à la Réunion connaît un
essor comme dans le monde en général et
nous essayons nous au niveau de la
Réunion apporter notre savoir-faire au
niveau des produits diététiques et
également importer donc des matériels de
sport qui soit des rapports qualités
prix très intéressants le magasin
Fitness Boutique est implanté à l'île de
la Réunion depuis le mois d'août 2012
donc dans la ville de Saint-Pierre et
dans le cas de notre stratégie
commerciale nous allons ouvrir une
deuxième boutique au mois de février à
Saint-Denis
nous allons consulter donc un conseiller
vendeur le mois de février au niveau de
son parcours scolaire c'est un profil
type Bac Pro BTS Force de Vente nous
souhaitons que le candidat puisse
maîtriser les techniques de vente les
négociations commerciales quelqu'un qui
est un esprit d'équipe esprit
d'initiative qui soit responsable et qui
surtout un sens de l'écoute très
important parce qu'on doit être capable
de discerner les besoins du client pour
lui proposer les produits dont il a
besoin de conseiller vendeur sera seul
au magasin donc il devra vraiment être
responsable être parti prenant dans
toute l'activité de l'entreprise parce
qu'il est également la vitrine de
Fitness Boutique dans ce magasin à
Saint-Denis
un conseiller vendeur diététique doit
savoir accueillir écouter et dialoguer
avec sa clientèle
assurer la mise en rayon qualitative et
la disponibilité de ces produits
fidéliser sa clientèle
pratiquer régulièrement une activité
sportive
que nous recherchons et ça c'est un fait
qu'on peut voir donc des premières
minutes c'est que la personne soit
vraiment motivée qu'elle sache se vendre
et qu'elle est surtout aussi de
l'assurance sur sa position et sur
l'envie de travailler au sein des
magasins Fitness Boutique
bonjour je m'appelle Alex j'ai 29 ans
j'habite à Saint-Denis et je cherche un
poste dans la vente j'ai eu mon bac
économie sociale au début 3 à
Saint-Denis j'ai ensuite passé une
licence une première année de licence à
Lyon 2 et j'ai aussi mon caces 3 5 pour
la logistique tout au long de mon
parcours professionnel mais j'ai eu
plusieurs expériences dans la vente que
ce soit ici à la Réunion ou en métropole
en métropole je travaille dans la vente
à Cabourg dans les ventes aux enchères
et à la Réunion je travaille à Jules et
à la Grande Récré j'ai aussi plusieurs
expériences dans la logistique où j'ai
été cariste et chef de quai dans une
grande multinationale qui est jeudi
aromatique j'ai aussi travaillé dans le
domaine
ferroviaire où j'ai déchargé chargé des
trains je connais donc les règles de
sécurité dans un grand dépôt et aussi
dans un dans une gare je suis aussi un
grand passionné de sport que je sais pas
pratiquer d'ailleurs je suis licencier
d'un club de foot j'ai fait beaucoup de
marches et de course à pied je suis très
souriant et dynamique je sais m'adapter
à toutes les situations
je suis très autonome et je sais
travailler seul ou en équipe maintenant
vous me connaissez un peu mieux j'espère
que vous me contacterez je suis
disponible dès demain et mobile
contactez-nous sur votre page Facebook
www.facebook.com/974 TV ou par téléphone
0262 92 37 60
votre émission au service de l'emploi à
la Réunion